your reaction to that which we are
learning about what happened in april
i think the events that took place on
that evening were wholly unacceptable
and completely insensitive and should
never have happened
but that said i don't hold the prime
minister personally responsible for
those because patently the prime
minister was not there
but it does reveal i think a culture
within downing street
um that obviously stems from the top and
should not be permitted
do you think of course as mentioned
you've submitted your letter uh to the
22 committee i wonder whether the
revelations all of last night might
serve to focus the minds of certain of
your colleagues
of themselves i would doubt it because
the prime minister was not present
it is just another
event in a chapter of incidents that
should not have happened
but i do think that minds are now over
this weekend being focused
upon the need to take the necessary
action
i clearly neil don't know
and i shouldn't know
how many of my colleagues have put in
letters i'm not canvassing them i'm not
seeking support for what i have done
myself
but i believe that there is a momentum
that is growing
yeah i mean you you must have had
communications from constituents perhaps
not necessarily related to the story the
the the individual story that came out
uh last night but about the the culture
it appears of drinking within number 10
during periods of lockdown i mean
is there not a real risk that the
conservative party
is going to lose vast swathes of
faithful followers simply because of
continued fealty to boris johnson
well i don't think that the image of the
downing street branch of the majestic
wine warehouse is doing us any good at
all
that that clearly has to end
but but there are it's much more
important and much more serious than
that neil
this goes back i voted against
the government on the internal markets
bill because i believe that it was quite
wrong for a british government to seek
to unilaterally break
a freely entered into international
treaty
you know there are serious political
issues about our standing in the world
that have to be addressed and i'm afraid
those issues lay straight at the
doorstep of the prime minister
given that
do we need to wait for the report of sue
gray to work out whether or not there is
any longevity to boris johnson's
political future i mean does it matter
now whether or not these events were
technically within the rules given the
public of program
i would expect that sue gray as a
responsible civil servant will produce a
holy factual report without
recommendations
she will say what has happened
and it will be up to the rest of us to
decide what then should happen
um but of course
in a sense we know because the prime
minister told us from the dispatch box
on wednesday what happened
and that's why having said i would wait
for the report from sue gray i went
public on on wednesday lunchtime after
prime minister's question time because i
believe that what was revealed was
completely unacceptable
do you believe that the metropolitan
police
should be involved in some form that
there should be an investigation perhaps
even just specifically on the events of
the eve
of the royal funeral
well that's a matter entirely for the
metropolitan police it's it's an
extremely long time since i held a
police warrant and um my law is a bit
rusty and i'm gonna try and presume to
tell the met what to do if they feel
that there is a matter if they feel that
laws have been broken
um and that it is necessary to
investigate then i'm quite sure that
they will do that the only problem with
that of course is that while we are
waiting for sue gray's report if the met
then become involved before that report
is published
that will then go on ice and it will
merely prolong the entire process
critical voices like yours have been
accused of of being in a sense that the
usual suspects nadine dora is saying
yesterday
colleagues like yourself had a track
record of not supporting the prime
minister
how fair or unfair do you think that
characterization is
um i have been described as a serial
critic of the prime minister in a sense
that's true
of my criticism my letter uh calling for
a leadership election goes back to
the barnard castle event when the prime
minister failed to take what i regarded
as appropriate decisions and action
to remove mr cummings from office
because what happened then was quite
wrong and i decided then that if the
prime minister was not capable of
exercising the right kind of judgment
then we had to have another prime
minister so yes i mean my track record
does go back a long way
but all i'd say neil is i have been
consistent
um i'm not and i've also tried to be
fair
to be fair the prime minister has
achieved some
significant uh results he's he's whether
i like it or not doesn't matter he's
delivered
on brexit as he promised he was going to
after a bumpy start he's presided over
the best
world beating vaccination program that
saved thousands of lives you can't take
that away from it the problem is that
the man's judgment is flawed
um so roger i'm afraid we will have to
leave it there so roger gail good to
have you in the program this morning
appreciate it